la destinée littéraire de michel
tournier est tardive il publie son
premier roman vendredi ou les limbes du
pacifique à 40 3 ans en 1967 premier
succès aussi pour cette variation autour
du thème de robinson qu'il impose
d'emblée trois ans plus tard il reçoit à
l'unanimité le prix goncourt pour le roi
des zones dont le metteur en scène
allemand volker schlöndorff vient de
tirer un film et qui reprend en
l'amplifiant l'allégorie légendaire de
l'ogre michel tournier décidément est le
romancier des mythes
trois ans plus tard on peut dire qu'il
achève son oeuvre avec les météores
fresque admirable axée sur la gémellité
tournier après tout est l'auteur de
trois livres essentiels le reste importe
peu
le roi des zones que gallimard propose
dans sa collection de poche commenté
folio plus est bien l'oeuvre d'un
germanistes fils de germanistes qui a
beaucoup séjourner en suisse allemande
et puis en allemagne et qui s'est formée
à ce que les allemands appellent
explicitement la germanistique le roi
des aulnes tire son titre d'un poème
fameux de goethe
l'écrivain allemand par excellence c'est
une histoire d'abel tiffauges garagistes
du quartier des ternes à paris que la
deuxième guerre mondiale précipitent aux
confins du reich dans cette prusse
orientale glacé où le maréchal goering
forme les futures élites de la wehrmacht
tiffauges il connaîtra une assomption
symbolique sauvant du désastre annoncé
un enfant qu'il porte sur les épaules
aucun lecteur jamais ne pourra oublier
le roi des zones